-Welcome back!
Guys, I am so excited,
because this weekend
is the Final Four.
It is happening down
in New Orleans.
[ Cheers and applause ]
These games are gonna be huge.
You got Duke taking on
their rival North Carolina.
You have the Kansas Jayhawks
facing off against Villanova.
It is impossible to predict
who's gonna go all the way.
But you're in luck, because when
it comes to predicting things,
we have a secret weapon,
and it's...puppies.
It is time for
"The Puppy Predictors:
2022 Final Four Edition."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Puppy Predictors ♪
♪ Puppy Predictors ♪
-Welcome to
the "Puppy Predictors:
2022 Final Four Edition."
Here's how it works.
We have eight puppies --
two for each team --
and one bowl of kibble.
Whichever team's puppy
gets to the bowl first
will determine who will be
crowned the national champs.
Now, let's meet the puppies.
For Duke, we have...
[ Audience "awws" ]
...Donna Braylon
and Kyle McAdams.
Good to see you, guys.
For North Carolina, we have...
[ Audience "awws" ]
...Mary Kennedy and Ted Mooney.
For Kansas, we have...
[ Audience "awws" ]
...Roger Blain
and Lisa Armstrong.
And for Villanova, we have...
[ Audience "awws" ]
...Terry Jackson
and Gary Frick Jr.
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
...before we release you
and we see who wins, I want to
keep this a clean, fair fight.
Hi, guys.
A very fair fight.
Okay, no wandering.
No butt sniffing.
Let's keep this clean.
You guys,
whenever we're ready to go,
please release the puppies.
[ Audience "awws" ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
Oh! It's nail biter!
I think we have a winner.
Do we have...?
♪♪
Do we have instant replay?
Do we know who?
Was it North Carolina?
Let's play the scene in
slow motion and see who won.
♪♪
Ooh, it's such a close...
It's like North -- Kansas,
but then North Carolina
sneaks in there.
Yeah, and gets in there.
It's North Carolina for the win!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
We have a winner right here.
North Carolina
will be the champs,
the 2022 national champs.
You heard it here first.
Enjoy the Final Four, everybody.
We'll be right back
with Sienna Miller.
Hey, you did well.
You did a great job.
Wanna go back down?
Wanna go eat?
Go eat. Go.
♪♪